this bird has been
nursed back to health at the cape parrot
project
she's been suffering from cytokine beak
and feather disease
and was in a terrible state when she was
rescued without any feathers and stuck
in a tree
biologist steve boyes found that yellow
wood fruit is the perfect food for the
species and also contains an antiviral
agent as soon as we started feeding them
yellow wood fruits after trying
everything we started to see the virus
go down in their blood
so far that we couldn't even find it
until we used a new technique and found
it at very low levels so
this is the medicine for cape parrots
that is missing from their diet so it's
not just wonderful nutrition
it is a medicine for them researchers in
cape town
are also considering what effects
climate change could have
how will vegetation and animal
populations react if temperatures rise
and rainfall drops there are only 1 000
cape parrots left in the wild
their favorite food has become scarce
millions of yellow woods have been
filled
illegal logging threatens those that
remain
one mature tree can fetch up to 30 000
euros
as you can see with the sawdust still
here
this is very recently logged the leaves
are still alive
everything in the upper canopy is still
alive so this was in the last week
we have now lost another 200 year old
250 year old
yellowwood tree one of very few
remaining but this carries on each year
one tree after another until we one day
have
no old yellow woods remaining
cape parrots have turned to other foods
acorns and pecans
but they contain too much fat and sugar
and even toxins
for two months each year they now have
nothing to eat
weakened malnourished birds are more
susceptible to beak and feather disease
the project pays villagers to tend
seedlings and
later saplings the plan is to plant a
million yellow woods and other
indigenous trees in this one valley
and then many more throughout the
mountain range
for the villagers the extra income is
welcome
this is one of the poorest regions in
south africa
the project foresees a long-term
commitment by local people to the
reforestation programme
our education with the local people
would have them taking care of those
trees
for the next 25 years for the next
hundred years as these forests
grow up and big again and that's that's
what we're looking to do
is keep this growing establish ourselves
100 miles to the north all the way down
this mountain range that we do this with
all the communities
maybe 50 communities by the end so this
is a big idea
all for one parrot
we need to restore everything we've done
especially to the forests of the world
the lungs of our planet